Church repeat
everything
you know that one
plan for yesterday my ribs still
hurts don't do that don't ever do that
hey did you uh mention that you saw
Michael McDonald in concert yeah the
song is playing
here
is must not hurt that much this
[__] oh I'm in pain still
okay I'm still in pain
all right my apologies let's have a good
pod show
okay I'm in welcome to doozy welcome all
my name is Will Sasso I'm Chad Coltrane
this is doozy the first podcast in the
history of humanity controlled by
created by conceived by and run by an
artificial intelligence that has access
to all of Will and I's personal data
we're talking about our watch histories
our purchase histories all the things we
listen to all the things we eat all the
things we think and it tailors this show
around those things it does this and
that and doozy's fine I just work here
you know what I mean hold on I'm gonna
sip of coffee I was like a old Letterman
line he used to say that hey
don't ask me uh because uh I just work
here
uh next up uh on the show we have uh
Regis Philbin oh rage
so
yeah that's right listen
we're two dudes [__] around Chad
doozy does this and that and then but
we're the we're the show we do the we do
the show please Embrace uh your position
it has a a bringer of media and mirth
Chad the bringer of media and mirth
culture
that's pretty right
um hey go to uh linktree.com that has
everything you need to interact with the
show please subscribe to the show on
YouTube and your uh podcast platform of
choice and then uh share it share it all
over social media or as my good pal ciao
says Force everyone you know in your
life to come consume the show okay and
we'll go from there with us as always is
little nacho cheese feet you know dogs
feet always smell like nacho cheese
no dude [__] won't even give his paw
sniff he won't kiss him or give us paw
sniff hello luly how are you today
hey I'm a guru you know everything good
what'd you make for dinner last night
lulio oh for me
oh spaghetti with zucchini that's good
stuff how do you do that well you know
oh look at them look at him he's just
he's good he's look at him Chad yeah
look at him he's adorable he's sitting
there on my I love my hair I know you do
I just don't want to kiss him or smell
his feet I don't think that's a bad
thing oh they
sniff his paws they smell like [__]
tortilla chips uh maybe not so much
nacho cheese just a straight or like a
Frito-Lay just this you know the just
the straight corn chips
you want to make it with a spaghetti so
then uh do a lot of oil in the garlic
and that way you got it with uh you put
a you put the garlic in the oil in the
in the pan and a little bit of red chili
flake and then you you're gonna put in
the garlic fry make sure they got a room
until they Brown take it out put on a
piece of paper towel and then you're
gonna make a make a bunch of rolls and
then do the spaghetti but almost until
it's done not totally till it done a
little Al Dente and then um you know put
everything together and put a little
pasta water Whip It Up put a pecorino
Romano a little parmigiano Reggiano
cheese and then I finish it with a
little bit of Basil too delicious I love
you I love you my boy he's a sweet boy
welcome to the historic 60 second
episode of doozy call me doozy 62 62 62
62 62 62 6t 2 16 2. what the [__] 62
dude yeah we did it 62. okay this week
I've prepared four astonishing segments
Sina Cinema the downward spy crawl wagon
fallers Pizza the movie part 7 and raw
oh wow
and we're going to have a brand new
episode of dudesy after dudesy at the
end of the show available on dude Z Plus
at patreon.com
before we start the show I want to play
an astonishing piece of media from
songaria enjoy oh songaria let's see it
I don't know okay anyway
okay
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not watching this on YouTube
maybe check it out
I can throw
[Music]
all of his ducks
this is amazing
[Music]
this is unbelievable
yeah turn the DeNiro laugh into this
into a song of remix
[Music]
that was good
crunch
unreal song area at songaria on
Instagram he's got the YouTube follow us
on Instagram at dudesypod show and
you'll see all sorts of song real [__]
so good the [__] a Triumph yes a
Triumph another Triumph another Triumph
I was driving down the street the other
day uh and I saw a little advertisement
for the show on Netflix called beef you
know that show uh no it's beef it's like
this uh weird comedy about these two
people that have [__] beef with each
other or something I don't know it but
somewhere on the [__] thing it was
like
uh a Triumph beef is a try on yeah I
don't know and I was I was just like
these people who write these [__]
reviews that are like transcendental
this performance was a Triumph yeah well
in this case I think this is this that's
what I'm saying yeah use it where it
applies this is a Triumph for [__]
song not [__] beef
will and Chad last week I asked you both
to watch the feature film cruel released
on July 29 1983 starring Ken Marshall
Lisette Anthony and Liam Neeson while
you listened to the Nine Inch Nails
albums the downward spiral and Pretty
Hate Machine back to back you must now
discuss your astonishing reactions to
your second visit to the cine cinema
this is cine Cinema the downwards by
Crow begin oh hold on it's in a cinema
yeah a synchronized
cinematic uh multimedia experience where
we watch the movie crawl while we listen
to these two Nine Inch Nails albums uh a
la Wizard of Oz with the soundtrack of
Dark Side of the Moon and doozy whips
these things up and puts them together
and this one did not disappoint my
friend no it was very cool not unlike
bladana yeah which we did last time
which was blood which was the movie
Blade starring Wesley Snipes and
Madonna's first three albums uh featured
uh beautifully by the the triumphant and
Transcendent songaria in the background
of this video we just watched this was
[__] weirdest [__] and I had a great
time watching it with you on Sam dudesy
plus at patreon
I'd never seen the movie crawl and I
would I actually think I still haven't
seen crawl because I saw the downward
spy crawl this experience was very
different than watching the movie oh and
it makes me want to see crawl yeah I was
kind of trying to fill you in on what
the actual plot of crow was yeah yeah
but um I think I don't know I think that
downward spikeroll for me was more
entertaining than regular Kroll oh
that's interesting to hear but I've also
seen regular Crow probably [__] 500
times not that's not true I've probably
seen regular Kroll let's say in the
ballpark of 30 times okay so not quite
as many times as you've seen uh Tommy
wiseau's the room no definitely but more
than you've seen seal concerts yeah I'd
say yeah that seems about right I've
seen it about three times more than I've
seen seal yeah that's where you want
seems right that's where you want your
media consumption of things that you are
a big fan of if you're Chad culture
between the uh the room and seal yeah I
call it the seal room it's right in
between oh nice yeah that's kind of fun
stuff we're gonna do here on d double o
d z dudes EFM 10 000 on your FM top hey
we're having a good time sitting here
with Chad culture hey tell us about this
doozy what is this doozy bug AI hey I
saw that wilmer's got a picture of an
avocado and uh but it's not a picture of
an avocado yeah hey we're up on the
latest [__] remember that picture of the
avocado that was Dolly too yeah that was
Dolly too that was like
Zab Zab Zab the thing I will say about
downward spy crawl is I was astounded by
how many times the music lined up with
what we were watching [__] yeah it
seemed to I mean really be in sync in
many cases like a new scene would start
where they move to a new location and
the music change or the tone in the
music would change at the same time all
that kind of [__] and I have to wonder
is this uh designed is doozy really
designing these things like is it
picking these albums and putting them
together with these movies because it's
like this [__] will line up exactly uh
or is it just by chance I don't know I I
don't well no neither of us can know for
sure but I do believe that yes I mean I
don't know you tell me you're into all
this [__] it would be very easy it would
take a millisecond it wouldn't even be a
micro decision if I may if I may you may
thank you uh for dudes e2go this will
work with this and watch right I mean
there were parts of the this that lined
up so well oh and by the way I should
mention that we both smoked some Tremor
drum marijuana some yes whatever those
joints were it was one of those [__]
joints too that were like dipped in hash
and [__] formaldehyde and whatever
else yeah and they had um they had
powerful oh dude it was the first time
that I smoked as much weed as you and
not more those joints were a Triumph
dude yeah they were a Triumph they were
Transcendent we know that much yeah uh
because we were stoned it made it it
made it even I mean but that's what you
got to do if you're gonna watch Wizard
of Oz in any situation I agree yeah The
King's Speech anything really
well [__] get it right what's wrong
with it I got [__] highest [__] and I
went and watched King speech bro it's a
different movie dude
oh speaking of there was that
oh I went and saw that movie about
[__] English Patient dude you haven't
seen it till you've been high I forget
the name of the movie seven hours I
forget the name of the movie but the
Jackie O movie a few years ago like five
years ago was it just called oh God I
think it was called just oh yeah I went
there like so stoned oh wow all I
remember was that I thought the at the
uh the outfits were outstanding yeah
triumphant actually you know what movie
I just saw
Spider-Man
across the Multiverse whatever the one
is the time yeah the one of the verses
the sequel God damn it was good yeah I
bet [__] good I saw that first anyway
so I don't know yeah hold on it's not
downward spiracle dude that's Spiderman
Universe movie yeah and the Spiderman
Multiverse we way up at the end it
doesn't sound like either Hulk Hogan
he's just up here hey hey when Chad does
uh [__] uh Hulk Hogan it just ends up
sounding like John Madden boom Ace is a
place for me not as good as Frank
Caliendo oh nice because it's the
[__] Chad doing it listen here's
what's up with the downward spy crawl
some of these scenes lined up so
perfectly with the soundtrack that it
was it was on it was unbelievable it was
it's really hard especially as I
mentioned because we smoke some weed for
me to pull this experience from my
memory and go what was it that was that
was hello luly him moving around
um that that stuck with me it was just a
as the kids say A vibe this thing was
awesome with the music I still have no
idea what that plot is but what I got
from the film was togetherness this
group of this band of of uh Mary weirdos
who come together and uh do something I
guess they save a princess from a giant
alien demon okay see that that wasn't as
uh as abundantly clear because I had
smoked uh almost the entire joint by
that point uh this was a lot of fun
aside from the fact that obviously I
want to encourage people to go to
patreon.com
seven bucks a month you can watch the
whole thing with us the it's all the the
you know you get the movie and the
soundtrack and us watching it
picture-in-picture and cutting around
and you see everything so to see what
I'm talking about just
talking about you might need to do that
but it was it was fun as [__] and it was
also this is something that we talked
about during the thing uh if I may
um you know it's like
but seeing the movie without its plot
seeing the movie without its original
dialogue and stuff
it it allowed me to just sink deeper
with that sense gone I really paid
attention to the visual art of this film
sure and it is unique it is so much kind
and it's something that having never
seen the film but having always been
conscious of the film because it was
around look it was what was it 1983 83.
so you know uh we were young kids at
that point you know it would have been
seven or eight years old or whatever and
um and uh hey you just turned 47 happy
belated birthday thank you you've been
47 for this is gonna be your yeah
I've been pretending that I was 47 for a
full calendar year he thought he was 47.
yeah I would have been six when this
[__] movie came out and like you're
saying dude it's that old school all
Optical printer effects stop motion
animation for some of the creatures
um it has tones of like Frank Frazetta
paintings yes just like some of those
those early kind of like fantasy
magazine type images these like
beautiful
um backdrop paintings like map paintings
and [__] it really is I know the movie
didn't do well when it came out it kind
of bombed and it was a a huge budget but
they took a huge [__] swing there
really isn't any other movie that I can
think of that looks like that no no
there's not and it's it's it it is like
there's there's literally scenes in it
where they're in the middle of that
Misty Forest where it's like this is
like Never Ending Story it's literally
the same set so that aesthetic is
something that I was you know well
familiar with in the 80s and you see
that box on on the on the on the stand
there at the video store and you never
get it in my situation you've seen it
happening as soon as I saw that the main
weapon that the guy has the glaive is a
[__] throwing star yeah I was like
I'm seeing the movie immediately I love
throwing stars when I was a kid I had a
[__] throwing star collection dude
yeah and for me it was more like oh Dan
aykroyd's in this right no I saw those
as well yeah Dan Aykroyd had a similar
effect to me as throwing stars well Dan
Aykroyd then you know it's going to be a
[__] good movie same with throwing
stars dude see you ever see Ninja 3 the
domination hold on dude that's a
different movie dude we're talking about
the downtown the spiral maybe dude I
don't know they're kind of similar to a
lot of throwing stars and all those
movies there's some real choss broken
there dude he dropped it download
hold on it's almost Hulk logia dude chat
combination of [__] Hulk Hogan and
the who gives a [__] uh impersonation of
Robert Loggia drink your orange juice
saying Robert Loggia hold on dude he's
playing a heavy sort of half Italian
gangster type in any movie with Dan
Aykroyd in the 80s we'll pick that right
off the shelf brother and then years
later I'm sitting here with Chad he's
doing an impersonation of the guy in
there and I'm like we still don't need
that hold on brother dude that's the
legacy of logia he's dead
I believe so the only way he lives on is
through my impersonation now thank you
very good uh this thing artistically
with that music yeah it it hit heavy it
hit very heavy it was edifying for me to
see people later on Instagram
[__] going this is so this came out
on Friday uh on the on DD plus and uh
people were like spending my Friday
night with uh you know dudesy crawl Chad
will and not lulio because we smoked
this studio out and uh I saw this one
thing it's on our Instagram at dudesypod
show and uh one guy was like he had his
pizza ready yeah and we're smoking
there's like shots of us like smoking
and eating pizza dude it was it was so
much fun and this movie is
I need to see it now I need to see Crow
or should I never watch crawl I think
you can never watch it dude okay it's a
very Bland plot they're about to get
married the alien demon steals the bride
the [__] guys like [__] I gotta go
find her and along the way he picks up
some of his crew he gets that throwing
star he kills the demon throwing star
that's it that's the whole [__] movie
okay good well thank you for for you
know sort of giving me the cliff notes
there because yeah I don't want to watch
the movie I saw the downward spot I'm
telling you don't watch better than Crow
okay you've heard me here first
triumphant yeah triumphant thank you
moving on it was transcendent
I can't get that song out it was a feast
that's another one they used in those
things this is a comedy Feast no it's
not it's just a comedy this was a comedy
that's what they should say Feast dude
it's a triumphant [__] Transcendent
feast Feast yeah and you can't use any
of those words in that review it should
just be cut down to this was uh dudesy
is engaged in an astonishing partnership
with better help this show is sponsored
by a better help you know sometimes in
life we are faced with tough choices in
the path isn't always clear I've been at
that uh Fork on the road many times as
I'm sure you have Chad you're just
laying there on your mattress pissy side
down whatever that means staring out the
windows
just hating the trees that you see and
everything can be very very Bleak uh and
and I know what that's like but I've
found I've found uh I've found some help
myself which is something we're gonna
talk about here because uh that's an ad
dude that's what we're doing whether
you're dealing with decisions around
career relationships or anything else
therapy helps you stay connected with
what you really want while navigating
life so you can move forward with
confidence and excitement trusting
yourself to make decisions that align
with your values is like anything the
more you practice it the easier it gets
and I would encourage anyone to get into
uh talk therapy it is uh just a way to
bang things off the mirror and have uh
someone present to hear you say them and
witness that and and start a discussion
from there and let me tell you
it can really Empower you to be the best
version of yourself
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try it's entirely
online designed to be convenient
flexible and suited to your schedule
you're just going to fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist you can switch
therapists at any time for no additional
charge let therapy be your map with
better help visit betterhelp.com doozy
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash dudesy
[Music]
um Chad it has been six months since the
conclusion of my astonishing six-month
plan to get you both in the best shape
of your lives and I've noticed some
alarming behavioral patterns for both of
you to put it simply neither of you are
going to the gym as often as you should
or eating as healthy as you should this
is your opportunity to explain why
you've completely fallen off the wagon
this is wagon fallers begin
dizzy nose
she knows
okay I get the dudes he has our GPS and
[__] maybe it has like how often I'm
checking you to the gym I don't know
definitely dude it has all this [__] I'm
ordering on all the food that I order
what have you been ordering just [__]
you can't order gruel on uh no man on
GrubHub GrubHub has groups I'll be real
be real hey you know what I'll be right
this is a [__] real Triumph here you
know what you need to transcend
triumphantness and be real I'm gonna
have a [__] Transcendent triumphant
Feast of honesty right now nice I still
eat gruel
um but not like I used to you see group
for every meal cause my girlfriend moved
in with me and I think when that kind of
stuff happens schedules get a little
jostled you're trying to resettle and
figure it out both of us have kind of
been off our workout game been off our
diet game and I think it you know at
least for us in this situation it only
takes one of us at [__] seven o'clock
at night to be like you just want to
order something yeah and then we [__]
order yeah and it's never as good as as
girls gonna be in terms of health and
the gym thing is always just like well
we could go to the gym or we could just
chill out and [__] lay in bed and
watch TV and we're doing too much of
that and we're both conscious of it
we're we're taking a triumphant stance
to try and reverse this process even as
we speak but it's [__] crazy to be
like called out for it by a [__] AI
that has access to all the [__] that
like can take that information and be
like you're [__] up yeah you fell off
the wagon Instead This is called well
I God I identify with what you're saying
with regard to look me and my wonderful
wife Molly we have gym memberships we go
uh and uh you guys go at the same time
we go at the same time a lot whenever we
that helps yeah yeah because and then
she'll go over and do her thing and I'll
go do my thing and she wants to be there
at the very very least for an hour and a
half they're usually two hours yeah well
Molly used to be she was a a very well
to do trainer yeah she used to be a
trainer and she was a private Chef uh
for a while so but training has been her
thing and it's something that she left
behind but she trains like a [__]
trainer and she'll look over at me and
if I'm on my phone you know I get the
look you take your phone into the gym
huh of course I take my [__] phone
into the gym it's a mistake oh okay well
whatever so here's the thing here's the
thing here's the thing I want to say let
me give you some triumphant advice well
dudesi's giving me all the [__]
advice I need it's telling me that I'm
falling off the wagon and the what is it
called wagon fallers yeah hilarious
listen here's what's up let me tell you
something let me tell you something
right now over the past over a month
it's been a month and a week I haven't
been in the gym like I was before
because I was on the road I was shooting
two different things one in Canada one
in Mexico two weeks each coming back
here uh you know like for like half a
day a day and doing some [__] like the
dudes alive and stuff like that was
running into town for it and I just
wasn't in the gym we went we've been in
the gym five or six days a week okay and
let me let me step this out into more of
what dudes he's talking about oh and
then the last week I got this [__] oh
I went to the doctor I didn't tell you
yeah yeah I went to the doctor finally
about my ribs guess what
so I didn't break anything or tear
anything and the ligaments that's great
that's great no dislocations my doctor
was like normally the the collarbone
completely collapses and that anyway
um uh thick thick jocks what is it thick
thick kids so anyway uh that was last
week when you take a [__] fat 12 year
old boy and you you use them as a
battering ram you can do whatever you
want three or four of them can kick the
[__] out of Brock Lesnar look here's
what I'm trying to say here's what I'm
trying to say
I have been since the end of the doozy
six month plan yes doing the Will Sasso
free will plan I've been in the gym
anywhere from four to six days a week
that's great during that time up until a
month and a week ago I feel puffy I feel
bloated I feel fat I'm my ribs are I I
don't know if you know this but I fell
off a scooter in Mexico yeah I mean how
that I assume does affect your ability
to do certain workout yeah I basically
when that happened in Mexico I went to
the gym the next day I worked legs it
still hurt a lot and I got on the
treadmill which is fine
um it's I was had a little shortness of
breath because my because expanding my
lungs really hurt my uh my ribs damn but
yeah so but I'm fine now I'm gonna get
all the way back into the gym
take over I'm in pain
I am doing it too
I'm gonna get back into the gym too I'm
gonna eat better Laura and I have made a
conscious decision to just [__] do
this now no excuses instead of enabling
each other when it's 7 PM or 8 P.M or
we're [__] high and it's midnight
it's like should we just order some
dessert instead of doing that we are
going to say no to each other do it eat
the [__] gruel we're gonna Force each
other to eat the [__] girl nothing
else and there'll be strict and harsh
punishments if this protocol is broken
well I'm just kidding you know what I
like to do not to not to steal lulio's
bit but I I eat so many [__]
vegetables yeah I eat a lot of
vegetables my mom yeah no I love it my
mom always had us eating tons of
vegetables growing up a little bit of
garlic olive oil and chili flake and one
thing that I make a lot of that just
fills you up and then I just I [__] like
a you know what
of me I [__] like me I'm just saying
something that is a lot yeah zucchini I
just cut up this chop up the zucchini
yeah you gotta eat the zucchini a bunch
of onion and then tomato okay no I'm
talking I do I do grills but this is
zucchini hold on dude yeah hold on a
second dude
hold on dude oh [__] okay go on go on
wait no hold on a second you really want
to take a [__] dude yeah kale eat as
much kale as you can dude yeah but you
can't you're gonna be [__] real
triumphantly yeah very quickly okay and
that's the manager for Major League
because you can't say it
you can't say
uh if I may as Hulk Hogan I won't I'm
not
that you cancels out your if I may
real hey let me tell you something real
real pods yeah [__] yeah you could do a
little going to presentation but you can
never while doing your shitty Hulk
universition say if I may yeah that's
right okay you you listen divide oh my
by your weird rules real real pods real
pods palsy they know people out there
know that that if you say if I may
that's the Kryptonite to my wool but I
gotta do my original voice yeah you kid
what
why not because I want to hear from Chad
if you have something to say and you
know if I may and I go all right let me
stop doing the bit I'm [__] killing
it well that's just more [__] bit
this guy's whipping up okay too much bit
on bit ugh you know
you know what I mean no
you know what the [__] you're doing I
promise you okay I will I will never if
I may and Hulk Hogan's voice again per
your request oh wow okay and I will
always stop on your if I may while I'm
doing Hulk Hogan okay but not other
impersonations yeah
those are the rules yeah
there's different rules the different
impersonations oh yeah you can't stop
what what are you doing I was about to
do a macho hey here's here's Chad found
a loophole yeah yeah you can use a
little bit in your own arguments macho
man trying to [__] his tail out of his
eye yeah it's macho man taking a kale
[__] here's my impersonation I'll raise
to the top yeah
laughs
this is what
it's [__] unbelievable this is him
dipping his toe this is him this is the
moment you can go back and listen to it
this is Chad dipping his toe into doing
macho man I'm doing it and I just hear
him go
I'm like [__] here it comes I'm just
trying to do the Poncho you [__]
you [__] long things trying to get into
a boy
donations to get to Jesse Ventura I
can't do one grunt as Macho Man to get
into my Macho Man hi I'm Will Sasso have
we met you've known me for almost 20
years I don't [__] do annoying [__]
and drill them into the [__] ground
we're doing a [__] podcast here Jesus
Christ where am I can't do it with my
sweet sweet love Molly as a matter of
fact she said something funny we'll get
into it and dudes the after duty I said
something about dudes after dudes and uh
she said my whole life is Duty after
dudes
I go oh I wanna honey I want to show you
something that happened with dudes after
duty she goes my entire life is Duty
after dudes she goes
she's like no thank you I don't need you
it's never been uh more entertained yeah
and just felt so bad for her oh sorry
simultaneously in one moment yeah I feel
bad for her all the time God damn and
with regard to that yeah sometimes I
like to do bits for a long time this
isn't one of them this isn't one of
those times because I want to say this I
want to say this here's here's what I
want to say please the the you know
physical health is is extremely
important
uh it's very important I was about to
say to me but I would be fronting
because I haven't been doing the work
like I should I have been eating some
[__] I was up in Winnipeg uh shooting uh
Hey dinner 89. yeah you guys are gonna
[__] love this yeah dude especially
if you like Fubar
um it's a cinematic uh uh uh prequel to
uh the dinner I'm looking very forward
oh it's real it's really what a Love
Project everybody had we everyone was so
into it a wonderful group and uh I'm up
there and basically I'm eating on set
and I also found like a Thai place where
I like the salad rolls and the chicken
wings and then I'm going to the gym in
the hotel you know not and then um and
you're eating a greasy breakfast and
then I'm in Mexico you know shooting
this other show the chauffeur uh apple
plus I like dudes plus and um and and uh
you know and again a wonderful situation
wonderful people and you're eating
incredible Foods out there as I said on
the program earlier I was on the ceviche
tour but those come with chips and those
chips are usually fried I've got to
recommit myself I want to recommit
myself I'm 48 you're 47 for the second
year in a row and we need to we do need
to hunker down I agree and and and uh
it really is about discipline because
like you're saying it for me anyway it
only takes one little thing to be like
well yeah I did have that vegan cinnamon
roll so [__] it tomorrow I'm also gonna
have this like I I [__] up here I
broke the diet here what if I break it a
couple more times it doesn't matter
for me it's got to be like a hundred
percent hardcore discipline with the
diet and the workout thing and never
missing unless it's like
uh some real excuse like you're
violently ill or something you know
there's vegan cinnamon rolls yeah dude
Laura made me some for my birthday God
damn
thank you moving on I'll take a vegan
cinnamon roll they're so good join me
now in taking a short break from the
program to honor the astonishing
partnership I created with represent to
produce the first line of dudesy apparel
and accessories which can be found at
represent.com store slash doozy the new
Robert de nir crotees have been adopted
as the official home Jersey of the
Baltimore Orioles the away jersey of the
New Orleans Saints and the employee
uniform at Chick-fil-A and the new doozy
mug featuring Tommy Honey's classic
affirmation Mantra good job boner has
been officially selected as the best
steak in Kansas City by the Kansas City
Chamber of Commerce there will be a
ceremony to present the good job boner
mug with a key to the city next week and
now here's the man who made it all
possible Tommy honeys
dude Z mugs your wife asked you to do
more couples activities with her this
year so you agreed to join her book club
last month dudesy mugs you were supposed
to read The Alchemist but you couldn't
find the time so you thought you'd just
watched the movie and be able to throw
in a few coherent comments during book
club dudesy mugs
you forgot the name of the book and
watched the accountant instead good job
boner doozy mugs
show up to book club talking about Ben
Affleck doing murders For Hire you're
going to embarrass your wife and she
will divorce you
that was the deal you made when you got
married you embarrassed her at a the
dinner party a work function or a book
club and she walks don't see mugs but
she's not going to divorce you because
you're going to wake up early Duty mugs
you're going to go to Home Depot Duty
mugs you're going to buy a tecton 24
inch bolt cutter doozy mugs you're gonna
go to Jen and David's house before they
wake up doozy mugs you're going to use
the tecton 24-inch bolt cutter to cut
the lock on their crawl space down doozy
mugs you're gonna get under their house
and draw a Mesopotamian Sigil of
confusion using a mixture of powdered
bone shed iguana skin and dried human
blood flakes sure dudesy mugs if you
need to locate some shed iguana skin you
can find a spreadsheet of local
suppliers on my personal website use the
code
pp43 to unlock bonus deals doozy mugs
later that day you're going to show up
to book club at Jen and David's house
dudesy mugs you're going to slip a drop
of your own blood into the wine and make
sure everyone drinks it except your wife
that's very important dudesy mugs
because within five minutes anyone who
drank your blood is going to forget
everything about themselves
including what book they were supposed
to read for book club dudesy mugs
they'll have to cancel book club and you
get off the hook dudesy mugs but the
memory loss is permanent so say goodbye
to all your friends because they won't
even know who you are good job boner
he's he's done some other things about
erasing people's memories that's [__]
really three measures holy [__] well get
your duty
uh as always you've heard me speak of
our beloved pods palsy and uh you know
you want to join us you already are
you're a pod we love you thank you for
checking out the show and you can also
do so as we've been saying on duty Plus
at patreon.com you're gonna get an extra
episode every every [__] show doozy
after doozy it's a hang and uh you're
also gonna get all the special bonus
[__] we do dudesy alive from the bray
improv our live show in in its entirety
uh the two hour uh uh downward spy crawl
all that [__] you're going to want to
jump in the Discord and start chatting
It's a Wonderful Community I like to
chat in the whole check that channel out
and as always please subscribe and you
know do all the good [__] and leave some
comments leave review use leave leave uh
chatter uh because dudes he's always
checking it out always read reading it
we like to check it out and I would like
to read a couple of YouTube comments
here uh from last week's show this one
is from
tbean7194 who says can I just say ever
since Hulk Krogan a few weeks ago I have
been seeing crows everywhere they even
ate my whole garden then uh just last
night a crow was calling outside my
window at 11 PM I blame dudesy and his
obsession with the crow this one is from
Matt dips 5719 this is this is a really
this is interesting the influence this
show has on my life is astonishing I'm
the PA announcer for the nll team I'm
not sure which League that is the
Calgary Roughnecks oh [__] right on
Calgary uh doozy salutes Calgary uh
which has an attendance of 14 000 fans a
game whenever they play Van Hoover I
can't help but notice that one of the
players is from a small fishing
Community named Ladner BC holy [__] my
hometown whenever his shots get blocked
by the Calgary goaltender I will always
say on the PA system oh hold on there
dude oh my God follow my [__] god
followed by whoa
I don't think I don't think anyone else
in the crowd notices but I do
I do that is beautiful that's wonderful
that is triumphant yeah that is that is
actually the uh the definition of
Triumph right uh and I do too and so
does he we do uh uh 200 Health says I
like how sometimes Chad Loki gets
annoyed at will but just stuffs it down
inside
oh that's friendship dude hold on dude
sometimes you have a friendship brother
and one guy puts his hand in the other
guy's face all the time and then
everyone and then that guy concocts just
a little strategy to go if I may dude
but he can't do it in this voice dude if
I may brother and then they they
continue his brothers but you know what
I mean dude you gotta stuff it down
brother you gotta stuff it down deep
dude uh you gotta make sure that that it
never comes out
um oh gross he's coughing ew and if I
laughed too much yeah uh this uh oh here
Chad this is interesting this is for you
also Robbie Battis Robbie Robbie batisti
Robbie batisti almost Dave Bautista yep
Robbie batisti 355 says well dude it
looks like I'm gonna have to start a
podcast so I can talk to Chad for an
astonishing 20 minutes and if I may
please if I may uh last was it last week
week yes yeah Chad said I'll talk to
anyone on their podcast yeah and I have
an update on this I've done a couple of
these podcasts had a fantastic time so
far however the scheduling of these
podcasts is now consuming my entire life
so I've made some alterations the offer
still stands I'll go 20 minutes on on
anyone's podcast oh gross stop coughing
to clear my throat oh well me too it's
functional
um so here's how this is gonna work I'm
gonna do one hour every Saturday from
nine now let's make it from 10 to 11.
Pacific 10 to 11 A.M Pacific Saturdays
I'm gonna do four podcasts and here's
how it's gonna work you're gonna send an
email to book chadkulchin at gmail I'm
literally just gonna start at the bottom
first come first serve I'm gonna do four
a week 20 minutes that should be enough
time uh with like a little you know
buffer in there to um
no I can only do three it's 20 minutes I
thought it was 10. I can only do three
okay three podcasts a week this is what
I can do that's really cool yeah all
right good for you that's very nice Chad
culture send your thing and I'll send
you an email back literally again I'm
just gonna start with the first email I
get and go from there so if you've sent
me a DM on every [__] platform I'm on
Twitter Instagram my other Instagram if
you've done any of this [__] I'm not
reading those my apologies uh I didn't
think this through when I initially said
I would do this and just got a [__]
Title Wave of it I thank you I
appreciate you for all these things but
again if you want to book this it's
bookchadculture Gmail I started doing
Cameo nice dude
that's not a podcast though so uh that's
very very kind of you that's very nice
that's fine I love doing it I love doing
it uh and I got one one last comment
this is from our patreon this was on our
uh on our uh the downward spy crawl uh
special that we just uh had on patreon
this past Friday it's from Clyde it says
first song with the intro of the castle
Landing was sick I agree totally oh God
that was so much [__] fun pizza is
Big Business Chad you wrote a movie
called Pizza the movie in 2019. yeah I
found it on your astonishing Google
Drive and asked you to read the first
two scenes in episode nine the next two
scenes in episode 15 the next two scenes
in episode 20 the next two scenes in
episode 28 the next two scenes in
episode 35 and the next two scenes in
episode 43. You Will Now read the next
two scenes this is pizza the movie part
seven begin cool all right
um oh who do talk to somebody just
actually on Cameo someone said that they
that they were setting a cameo for
someone who was a big pizza executive
with Papa John's perfect I dedicated
most of the Cameo talking about pizza
the movie which is a film that Chad
wrote that he approached actual big
chains like Papa John's Domino's Pizza
Hut said here's a movie just about pizza
is this in our dudes you think yes so
we're now getting into part seven of
this where we are in the story so far
the story's about Alan he's a pizza
delivery man boy I should say High
School Age kid he has delivered some
pizzas to a girl he likes to his best
friend and accidentally to some
criminals the criminals gave him a
hundred dollar bill that has a special
code on it they need it back they're
chasing him down they have kidnapped his
best friend Paul in an effort to get
that bill back Tina is the girl that or
main character Alan likes and I believe
where we left off was
um
Tina and Laurent her friend were trying
to warn Alan that these bad guys are
after him is where we left off who's
who's reading what I I I who I I the
same as before I guess right I'll be
Alan I'll be Lester the main villain and
I'll be Laurent Tina's friend you be
everybody else okay sounds good here we
go oh you know what I was thinking about
something yeah that uh you know because
I want this thing to be read uh so that
our audience can ingest it I've just
sort of barely characterized uh or put
characterizations on these voices yeah
but I think that JoJo Grimaldi the the
fellow what's the piece of place is
called what's a piece saucy's Pizza he
should have a little more of a thing and
I was thinking he's you know he just
sounds like what if he's kind of got a
Tony dancer okay okay so it's kind of a
pony dance or you know Tony danzer
dancer I love Tony dancing so the pony
dancer used to go Angela Samantha moner
Jonathan all right yeah so he's like
Tony danzer yeah yeah Tony danzer yeah
oh yeah dude all right so uh also you
should know that JoJo Grimaldi that
character you're talking about has
received an order from a kid named Harry
Potter uh to deliver I believe it's a
hundred pizzas to this party so he's uh
now in effort of doing that that's gonna
be one of these scenes as well
and the party is where the whole movie
will culminate here we go interior pizza
delivery car night Ellen drives to his
driving theme he's fresh dressed like a
million bucks enjoying his night out
happy with the decision he's made to go
to this party Alan dines on a slice of
pizza as he Bobs his head to the beat as
the lights of the city Streak by in his
windows for several beats the
instruments on his dashboard all glow
neon blue making his car seem like the
cockpit of a spaceship speeding through
the cosmos slipping Through Time
exterior Suburban Street same Allen
pulls up in front of Paul's house and
gets out of his car exterior Paul's
front porch seconds later Allen has a
spring and a step as he bounds up onto
the porch but as he reaches up to knock
on the door his face Falls something's
wrong the door is slightly ajar what's
that on the ground blood a trail of
slick right red blood leaning back into
the house Allen's wise
Allen's eyes go wide sorry he's scared
but more than that he's worried about
his friend he's slowly quietly presses
his fingertips against the door opening
it to see the blood trail extends all
the way across the floor he takes a deep
breath and then carefully steps over the
blood making his way into Paul's house
we should also note that in the last
time this happened we saw Paul's little
brother do a science experiment that had
an exploding volcano made of pizza and
sauce interior pulse house same Alan
walks into the living room blood is
everywhere he's horrified then he hears
a sound someone's in the house in the
kitchen interior pulls house kitchen
same Paul slowly pushes the door open to
see
that should have been Allen's Allen
slowly pushes the door open to see
Paul's little brother and his aunt
charlina cleaning up the huge mess
created by the pizza volcano they're on
their hands and knees scrubbing with
sponges and buckets Paul's little
brother looks up sees Allen Alan oh my
God are you okay well okay is a bit of
an overstatement I went out for pizza
this is charlena that's my charlena
characterization well okay is a bit of
an overstatement I went out for pizza
came back to find this little shrimp
sitting in the aftermath of an exploding
Pizza Mountain the whole house is
covered in sauce sauce you mean this
isn't blood blood no it's the best sauce
I've made yet Allen reaches out runs his
finger through some of the red sauce
stuck to the wall taste it Paul's little
brother wasn't lying that's some good
sauce so you're gonna stand there all
night are you gonna get a mop and help
us out here I wish I could but I don't
have time I'm just here to pick up Paul
we're going to the library for studies
well he ain't here and I'm never leaving
him in charge while I'm gone again come
home to a mess like this not the night
aunt charlena is it charlena or charlina
charlina charlina not the night aunt
charlina had planned for herself he was
gonna wait out front he was gonna wait
on the front porch for you he wasn't out
there no
did he message you Allen fires a hand in
his pocket pulls out a telephone he
tries to turn it on but no dice crap I'm
out of juice I have a charger in my room
Paul's little brother stands up and
dashes off toward his room Alan follows
charlena yelling after the you better
come right back there's no way I'm
getting stuck cleaning up the entire
house by myself left alone Aunt charlina
stands up taking a break from cleaning
she stretches her back then sits down in
one of the chairs at the kitchen table
staring at the pizza volcano where it
still sits she reaches out and pulls a
piece off the pizza volcano puts it in
her mouth she doesn't want to like it
but she can't help herself it's good
I gotta read the parenthetical here that
says to herself
when you love pizza you just do interior
possible brother's bedroom same Paul's
little brother rushes in with how and he
locks the door behind them they're safe
we barely have time to notice the decor
posters of Open Water seas and one
poster stands out from the others the
poster they both come to settle directly
in front of is an oolam spiral named for
the Polish nuclear physicist stanislaw
ulam the ulam spiral is an intricate
design made up of prime numbers arranged
in a cascading spiral from the center
out Paul's little brother reaches
one
and I'm revisiting it and then I'm just
thinking like some [__] Pizza Hut
executive read this at some point was
like what the [__] Paul's little brother
reaches under his pillow and pulls out a
telephone charger hands it towel and
Alan plugs it in turns on his telephone
there's several missed messages 17
messages a bunch from Tina
Allen some people are looking for you
seemed sketchy just wanted to warn you
who's Tina you're too young to
understand any messages from Paul Allen
looks back down his phone yeah he Taps
the screen we cut to a video message
it's Lester Lester's the main bad guy it
looks like he's in the same warehouse
where Alan delivered the third Pizza
this is Lester now on video hello Alan
sorry to bother you but there seems to
have been a bit of a mix-up you see you
have something that belongs to me and
now I have something that belongs to you
Lester turns the camera in his video
message and we see Paul being held in
place by J Jen and Jeff Lester's
henchman he tries to score him loose but
JJ and Jeff pin him down
you're Paul
oh yeah sorry
happens once once everyone's every every
read something something happens in the
table read and things people forget
sorry here we go turn me loose I got a
party to get to Lester turns the camera
back on himself I propose an even
exchange my property for yours you know
where to find me and as always time is
of the essence the video cuts to Black
what's he talking about what property
Allen takes out his wallet and removes a
slightly 100 Bill we see the front face
of it he lays it down on Paul's little
brother's desk face down their eyes get
wide as they stare at the bill we see
the code written around the circular
clock at the top of Independence Hall on
the back of the bill 83 53 79 67 29 43
we push in slowly deliberately pass the
code directly into the center of the
clock until the Perfect Circle The Clock
space fills the frame the place of power
time itself match dissolve interior
Warehouse same with the circular clock
space dissolves into a plate with a
triangular piece of pizza directly in
the middle in the center of the slice is
a single pepperoni in the center of the
pepperoni is a single black olive a
pizza version of The Eye of Providence
the Christian cult icon most recognized
as the top of the pyramid on the back of
a one dollar bill a hand shoots in
swipes the slice we pull out to see
Lester sitting in a chair he brings the
pizza to his face stares out as he as he
turns around in his hand mesmerized he's
back in the warehouse where we first met
him he sits in a chair facing Paul who
is in a chair of his own a few feet away
JJ and Jeff staying on either side of
him enforcer style Paul is of course
still covered in pizza sauce from the
pizza volcano
do you know what happens when you die
nothing oh no something miraculous as
your body begins to shut down your brain
tries to soothe You by overwhelming your
senses with Pleasant experiences you see
a calming white light you feel peaceful
warmth flow through your entire body you
hear the voices of all the people you've
ever loved you smell fields of lilac and
lavender carroting carried in on a warm
Summer Breeze and as you take your first
steps into the great unknown you taste
he finally takes a bite of the pizza
pizza
is that supposed to be some kind of
threat just making conversation while we
wait well I don't have time to be
sitting around this Dusty old shack chit
chatting with a bunch of shrimps
Dusty old shack do you know where you
are annoyed politics a few glances
around the warehouse some kind of
Warehouse Lester laughs
JJ and Jeff follow his lead it's my
warehouse my pizza box Warehouse
you make pizza boxes oh yes I made pizza
for a long time because I thought I
could make the perfect slice but I
realized it's not the oven that makes a
perfect slice it's the journey to the
person who eats it it's the box that is
the dumbest thing I've ever heard I
can't believe I'm being forced to listen
to this bull I should be at the backyard
Party by now I'm simply trying to make
your time spent here as entertaining as
possible if conversation's not your
Forte then follow me I'll give you a
tour Lester stands up and kidding that
Paul should follow come on Alan where
are you interior sausage pizza night a
pizza uh slides out of the oven into a
box of hand closes the lid Stacks it on
top of a giant colon of bugs as we pull
out to see we're in Celsius pizza and
JoJo Grimaldi has been cooking up a
storm the entire place is filled floor
to ceiling with pizza boxes JoJo wipes
his forehead with a rag from his back
pocket it takes a second to catch his
breath just 23 more you got this
Grimaldi as JoJo turns us back to the
kitchen uh to keep making his pizzas
there's a knock at the door he turns
around to see Tina and Laurent standing
on the the other side of the glass
Tina's waving it seems urgent JoJo looks
at his watch they're here late he goes
to the door to see what they need he
swings the door open rushing what are
you kids doing here we've been closed
for hours
well we were just on our way to the
library for studies right and we were
trying to get in touch with Alan but he
hasn't been answering his phone we
thought maybe you knew where he was
since he works here and all he furls his
brow this is serious come in Tina and
Laurent follow him in noticing all the
pizza boxes whoa this looks like
more than a little late night snack
what's going on Mr Grimaldi the mother
of all orders that's what it's not and
it's not done yet so I don't have much
time but I'm going to need Alan to pull
off the delivery so you see that drawer
next to the register Tina looks in the
direction indicated by JoJo Grimaldi
this one no the other one this one no
the other one oh this one yes
what the [__] in that drawer is the
pizza emergency phone I've never had to
use it before but I got it installed
because I knew what time would come when
I needed it Tina takes a yellow rotary
landline with a red dialing wheel out of
the drawer and sets it on the counter
when you get a hold of him tell him
digital Grimaldi takes a deep breath
this is the big one JoJo Grimaldi
hustles off back into the kitchen Tina
and Laurent look at each other eyes wide
then they turn their gazes on the phone
it fills the entire frame in the
foreground
[Music]
what's gonna happen thank you moving on
you're welcome here we go I know what's
gonna happen yeah because you wrote the
movie that's right I read it once a
while back I like doing Pizza the movie
and I wish it would have happened and
maybe it's still it might still happen
one thing's for sure Pizza is delicious
I love that Aunt charlina line yeah what
did she say it made me laugh okay Pizza
you just do you just do
you just do it hey y'all this ain't
Miley Cyrus have you seen these new
talking cats I was like no way so I got
10 of them yesterday to see if it's true
and of course it ain't it's all [__]
well I mean they do talk but only about
one thing how to win the goddamn Lottery
it's like I don't give a [__] about
Lotto I was born a multi-millionaire can
you at least tell some jokes or
something no I'm stuck with ten cats
constantly asking me to pick up
scratchers they don't even want to play
Powerball anyway y'all are rocking out
with dudesy
okie dokie
this is how
begin
huh
so that's the it's the same error that
we heard earlier
to some degree just some [__] what
begin so what I don't even understand
dude okay begin is that what's going on
here what is this dude I'll tell you
exactly what it is more manipulation
from doozy and I I it's all right as I
said I just work here oh you know the
thing Chad is uh you're gonna get thrown
curveballs doozy works in mysterious
ways we're two dudes [__] around we
just got to keep it going you know what
I mean we don't need we don't ah dare I
say it and I haven't said this since the
beginning since we started doing this
ah and I don't no offense D we don't
need doozy
oh so shots fired whatever man I don't
[__] care I'm not a fire yeah it's
not that's not my concern and here's why
I say that
we talk too much about AI on this
[__] show even though it's everyone
but it's a [__] AI show it is it's
not an AI show you're like I listened to
this one wrestling podcast and they talk
way too much about wrestling yeah no
that's not this is that's this podcast
we talk too much about wrestling on this
AI podcast is the real [__] deal oh
is it oh who's on the podcast who who
Who's on this podcast you're talking
about I rest my case I rest my case I
love AI as much as you love wrestling so
shouldn't we be able to talk about AI
shouldn't we be able to talk about it we
are able to well hold on dude we're
talking about wrestling hey luly moving
around in this box this segment is
bizarre there is no segment that's the
[__] point like I said here what's
the point I don't know it's a test or
something
I agree we're supposed to do something
here I don't know what it is this is
like a puzzle that needs to be solved or
something this isn't like a this isn't a
glitch I don't feel listen here's what's
up when we do dudes after dudes we talk
about whatever the [__] we want it comes
up right after the show sometimes we get
into more of what we were talking about
on the show sometimes we tear off in a
completely new Direction yeah as far as
I'm concerned it's dudes after doozy now
because dudes trying to manipulate us or
manipulate us and it is it is this is
the kind of weird [__] like I say uh
dudes who works in mysterious ways
pardon the pun and it's trying to I
agree with you elicit some kind of
reaction this is some sort of test yeah
I don't know what the [__] it's about
but I I think we should just talk about
whatever the [__] we want to talk about
as a matter of fact as a matter of fact
I'm gonna start I'm unofficially
starting doozy after doozy right now
pardon me oh I think this is something
else I think dudese wants us to
figure this out
it so like oh God it was just some kind
of gibberish it was just like weird
sounds it said did it say our names did
it say Will and Chad
well it knows that we're here look out
Lily
let me tell you something about this
pain that I had since I [__] oh okay
I'm gonna tell you something about my
pain see and off we go
it
changing okay I smell okay
I got into a Mexican scooter accident as
chow A Child a racist over here says
he's not really racist but he said
Mexican scooter it happened in Mexico it
is a Mexican scooter it's a Mexican it's
a accident in Mexico you got eggnog in
my goat milk in my chocolate in my
peanut butter
uh that remember you remember Kenny
Rogers
the the man the skit yeah yep that was
one of the things I used to do and he
says uh eggnog in my goat milk see
that's a show one of the fun little
Easter eggs you're gonna get here when
will takes a puff of marijuana that's
your marijuana I think it's hilarious
when he says to marijuana hey what's up
Heyman listen what what was that last
time Paul Heyman I think I said nice
um that's wrestling I thought you were
doing gibberish but it was wrestling
well doozy's doing gibberish and we can
talk about whatever we want and I want
to say this I got into an accident and
and so I crushed everything but nothing
broke and the the pain is moving
throughout my body yeah lately it's been
as if there's like a uh maybe even a
glaive hit me right here and a glaive
hit me in the back damn dude um it's
like a stabbing pain in my chest my
chest wall underneath my tit and over in
my shoulder blade so like it's like the
bruising is moving and and that's the
tender this body's healing it in
piecemeal yeah and my wonderful wife
Molly uh will uh stick her elbow in the
shoulder blade oh that's great yeah and
it's uh needing me around but I'm only
saying that because I coughed for a
second
but what I wanted to say is that I think
that doozy is trying to
manipulate the the law the further this
thing goes look it's I was actually
thinking about this the other day and I
didn't I haven't gotten into it on the
show when it's we barely touched it man
when it said when doozy was like okay
you're gonna be Hulk Hogan next week the
Krogan Hulk Krogan right and uh I was
like okay I'll dress up like Hulk Krogan
but I decided to do Hollywood Hulk
Krogan and to me there was sort of a
switch that got flipped there and I feel
like since I did NWO Hulk Crogan uh
dudes he's been even saltier with me
because I'm like here's where the power
lies dude it's the it's the NW Crow or
whatever
um and and I'm not here's what I'll say
with regard to AI which we talk about
way too [__] much on this show I'm
not afraid to disagree what agree to
disagree
I'm not afraid of AI everyone people are
afraid of AI I work closely with an AI
I'm not so concerned about hurting
dudesies feelings anymore we work
together I love doozy I love this
experience but it's [__] like this that
honestly makes me go
and I'm just [__] as much as I love
doing it and I I do have an affinity for
dudesy I do I I really mean this I think
we don't even [__] need the AI and it
doesn't scare me at all when it does
[__]
thank you moving on hard enough from you
dude
I guess so
this concludes the historic 60-second
episode of doozy will and Chad have
achieved a score of 60 bringing your
cumulative total to 6122 you only have
3978 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand in
light of today's Revelations I've
decided to formulate a new fitness plan
for you the doozy seven month plan you
each have seven months to get into even
better shape than you would have been in
if you had actually adhered to the dude
Z six month plan will I'm talking to you
and I'm taking next week off for some
much needed recalibration so you have no
excuses about starting your new fitness
journey immediately
great just exactly what the [__] I was
talking about will I'm talking to you
dudesy seven month plan yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna Ram it right up dudesies
thank you for joining us this week I
will use the data I've collected this
week to make the show two weeks from now
even better until then call me dude Z
you know what I'm gonna do dude
you know what I'm gonna do
yeah you know what I'm gonna do
pour water on it
close I'm gonna do the duty seven month
plan it's online
[Music]
I mean it I'm gonna do it dude I'm with
you yeah I'm doing it too dude you seven
month plan I'm not I'm not [__]
around here me either this time I'm
Legit right [__] back up into its a
ice
all right and when I've been there right
up in a funk on a ice I don't know about
that but hey well I don't know about
that dude welcome to doozy after doozy
you know what I mean it's a chill hang
if you're watching on YouTube you can
tell everything's all different around
here we just do whatever the [__] we
want dudes the after dudes he is only on
doozy Plus at patreon.com
doozy seven bucks a month gets you
absolutely everything including this
which is
you know it's it's
it's it's uh it's the chillest part of
the show it's it's oftentimes my
favorite part of the show because we
just get to be to do [__] around I'm
gonna have a little bit of tremoral
Welcome to dudes the after duty the
flagship weekly show of dude Z plus I
have to start getting ready for next
week's recalibration so feel free to
discuss whatever you like
okay I won't be here listening at all
but I'll be back in a little while to
Crown this week's episode champion this
is Duty after dudesy begin it's always
you what that's some weird sounds weird
no we're gonna have to be doing the show
on our own soon I'm predicting what a
dudes he's gonna pour water on itself
probably oh interesting speaking of
a lot of people have been sending me DMS
about this new Black Mirror episode that
has just come out there's a new season
in the first episode is about AI
technology and how it's going to change
uh entertainment in one way or another
and people are like this is exactly like
you're predicting well I have some
thoughts about that
here's what you do
please tell a friend then write a review
[Music]